Use Ai to fight bad guys.
Hello world,
it's Saroj and internet fraud is a huge problem and fraud techniques get more
sophisticated every day.
We'll build a demo APP in this video that uses AI to identify fraudulent
transactions from a transaction dataset.
Millions of consumers are victims of identity theft or fraud every year,
and that number seems to be going up in the past few years.
The numbers are pretty shocking.
Just last year there was a larger share of young people between the ages of 20
and 29 that had fraud complaints.
Then there were senior citizens age 70 or older according to a report from the
FTC,
and it's not even about how educated a victim is.
More than half of the people who suffered a fraud related financial loss had a
financial degree in 2016 today's fraud risks aren't just about payments.
All companies,
both small and large,
have to protect themselves and their users from identity theft,
fake user accounts,
man in the middle attacks,
there's a lot of risks to manage.
I really hope content got hacked and the world of cryptocurrency has opened up a
Pandora's box of deception from shady exchanges to pyramid schemes to pump and
dumps.
As you can see,
there's a massive need for solutions to help both consumers and businesses keep
themselves safe,
but how is this being done right now?
Over 90% of online fraud detection platforms use transaction rules to direct
suspicious transactions through a human review process.
This is a traditional rule based approach.
For example,
we could programmatically define that if a purchase is made in a dangerous
location like Zuckerberg office and the purchase amount is over some threshold,
then we can label it as fraud.
The result of this process is generally a binary labeling of a transaction as
either authentic or fraud.
The huge disadvantage here is that this process has a very high occurrence of
false positives.
That means just your average consumer wanting to make a purchase is going to get
flagged as fraudulent for no reason.
This is a big no,
no.
It means they won't shop at a business again,
since no one wants to be flagged for no reason.
It also means that businesses have to invest time and money into exhaustive
training for employees to work on manual review,
which ends up increasing the time required to fulfill an order.
There's gotta be a better way.
Consumers generate lots of data.
The web is rich with data.
It's everywhere and it's surrounds everything.
It's like the force IRL.
Why create rule based systems when we can use algorithms to learn from the rich
detailed datasets that consumers are generating just by browsing the web.
I mean machine learning is the science of designing and applying algorithms that
are able to learn from the past,
right.
Ai Can detect and recognize thousands of patterns of a user's purchasing journey
instead of the few captured by creating rules,
fraud patterns.
We wouldn't even think of tracking like time spent hovering the mouse over a
specific region of the screen.
While mining tron coin online businesses want fast,
scalable and efficient solutions for fraud detection and AI startups can provide
that for them.
Junio,
for example,
helps businesses authenticate potential customers by letting them take a picture
of their photo id and use their phone or computer to scan their face.
They use computer vision to verify that the person matches the photo in the ID I
iovation is another startup that helps businesses prevent mobile fraud by
automatically collecting information about the consumer's device.
For example,
eye ovation could notice a device was used to make a big purchase in the
previous 12 hours.
Then check to see if a phone number is connected to more than say three devices
and see if the purchase is coming from a high risk location.
Bio catch builds user profiles based on over 500 cognitive parameters including
behavioral patterns.
This way it learns what it looks like when fraudsters create accounts,
purchase products,
or even browse websites.
So how do we solve this problem using AI?
The first step in this process is to gather in segments some quality transaction
data.
If we can find this,
we can train a model on it to predict the probability of a transaction being
fraudulent.
Ideally we can find a labeled data set and we can use Google to find some where
each transaction is labeled as either valid or fraudulent.
A quality dataset is especially important in this case because we're talking
about the payments industry.
Usually government websites from across the world will be a good source for this
based off the types of transactions that are available to us.
We can pick a specific niche to target easily.
We can't verify our hypotheses of a potential solution by browsing online
communities where ecommerce business owners converse and see if they are having
the problem we're trying to solve.
Then share a landing page of our stealth product to see if we can get any
signups.
If we do,
we have market validation.
The main use case of machine learning in fraud detection is the prediction.
We want to predict the value of some help put that would be a boolean value in
our case,
fraud or not fraud given some input values like the country,
the card was issued in where it was used,
et cetera.
When we build our model,
we have to decide what kind of prediction problem.
This will be either a classification problem or a regression problem.
Let's pick classification.
Since we're trying to classify a transaction.
One very simple model to use for classification is a decision tree.
There are essentially a set of rules that are trained slash updated using
examples of fraud that clients face.
The creation of a tree ignores irrelevant features.
It can also be inspected visually so we can understand why a certain decision
was made by following the list of rules triggered by a certain customer.
It gives us a probability score of fraud based on earlier scenarios.
We can use the popular psychic learn library to do this in just a few lines of
code.
All of it can be done in python and the accuracy can be tested just as easily.
Another model we can use is called logistic regression.
This doesn't try to predict the value of a numeric variable given a set of
inputs.
Instead,
the output is a probability that the given input point belongs to in a certain
class.
It measures the strength of cause and effect relationships.
In structured data sets by assessing the predictive power of individual
variables or combinations of variables as part of a larger fraud strategy.
The authentic transactions are compared with the fraudulent ones to create an
algorithm and eventually it can be used to predict whether a transaction is
fraudulent or not.
We can do this with psychic learn as well.
Simple Algorithm,
few lines of code,
and we can train it locally,
but of course the real fun occurs when we apply deep learning that our neural
networks,
yes,
it requires a big dataset and lots of computing power,
but it blows all the other models out of the water in terms of accuracy.
If we have those two things,
so let's solve it or die trying.
Ideally we don't even need labels.
We could do this unsupervised.
In other words,
we could just remove the labels from our dataset.
So many different types of neural nets for us to choose from.
We need one that can learn and memorize the patterns of the normal transactions
during training,
since those are the majority of transactions on auto encoder would be perfect.
This is a type of network that approximates the function f of x equals x meaning
given an input x,
the network will learn to output f of x that is as close to aix as possible.
It will reconstruct the input as it's output.
Sounds counterintuitive and useless,
right?
Wrong.
The difference between the output and input is measured as the error.
It's what we tried to minimize during training so that the output looks more
like the input over time.
An autoencoder follows a typical feed forward neural network architecture,
except that the output layer has exactly the same number of neurons as the input
layer it the input data itself as its target value.
Half of the network is considered the encoder.
It's job is to embed the input data into a lower dimensional representation.
This is a group of numbers that represents the input data in the most dense way
possible.
Think of it like a compressed file.
The other half of the network is the decoder.
It tries to decode the embedded representation back into the original one.
We are relying on an autoencoder to learn the common patterns shared by the
majority of the training data during the reconstruction period.
The era will be high for the data points that don't conform to those patterns.
These are the anomalies were detecting which will hopefully be the fraudulent
transactions.
We can build this in tensorflow with the same amount of layers for both the
encoder and the decoder.
After training,
they will tell us transactions that are very likely fraudulent and we can apply
this learned model to the transaction data set of one of our first clients to be
saved.
We can manually review those transactions as well at first and continually fine
tune and improve our model algorithmically by adding more data and more
computing power.
If some transaction is above a certain threshold that we define in terms of
fraud likelihood,
we can put it on hold for manual human review.
Three closing points to remember wizards.
Fraud is a massive problem for online businesses.
It's nowhere near being solved and AI startups can offer them an awesome
solution to reduce it.
We can use decision trees,
logistic regression models,
and auto encoders to perform anomaly detection,
identifying fraudulent transactions in a Dataset and auto encoders.
Reconstruct the input data,
which makes it an unsupervised machine learning technique.
You made it to the end of the video.
Pat Yourself on the back and pat that subscribe button for now.
I've got to catch a fraudster,
so thanks for watching.